[Music]
all right so continuing to play bass
basic opening z45 i have three knight c6
and
okay bishop c4
so
this is an italian
and you know we can play bishop c5 we
can play knight f6
um the downside of knight f6 for
beginners is that you know allowing the
fried liver is not necessarily the
greatest option unless you've studied it
so
i feel like the
the move that's just a little less risky
at this level is to go bishop c5 i mean
here there are also very tricky lines
there's the evans gambit there's the
move d4
but it's not quite as dangerous if
you're not totally aware of the theory
okay so d3
we just continue developing knight f63
is the is the
modern main line this is what most gm's
play d3 and c3 but bishop g5 okay bishop
g5 is one of the many possible moves
in this position
and in the italian i i do like throwing
in h6
for many reasons um h6 is just a very
good move in italian structures
and
here g5 is a valid uh option this is one
of the possible lines
um there's many possible moves here
individual moves don't matter quite as
much here
the move that i like to play and this is
a move which
a lot of people might find uh some to be
some sort of a concession
uh it may seem that this move is a sign
that black is in fact worse but that's
not the case i don't love d6 because
then the pin is essentially permanent
unless you end up playing g5 afterwards
so
i quite like the move bishop e7 here
this is what i learned
and then we played d6
and i guess the reason that um
we're not against moving the bishop
twice is because white's bishop is also
sort of out of the game if you think
about it
if white's bishop drops back to g3
we're going to have a pawn chain that's
going to be biting on granite
if white's bishop doesn't
move back to g3 it's just sort of stuck
on h4 where it's not really doing all
that much
all right but h3 i think is believe it
or not a pretty serious mistake
um this gives us an opportunity to
transition to an immediate attack
the moment h3 is played right and your
opponent is castled you have to think of
this as a hook
and i've talked about hooks extensively
in previous speeders what exactly is a
hook
a hook is a pawn that's advanced
on the same side that
ah that the king is castled and that
advanced pawn allows you to put your
pawn on a certain square and open up the
king position right if you think about
it here if this g pawn moves to g4
he's basically going to have to take
which is going to allow us to take with
a bishop creating kind of a permanent
pin against the knight and because we're
not castled yet that is one of the great
advantages of delaying castling in
certain positions we can play g5 really
without thinking twice because we will
be able to castle queenside
if we want to we can keep our king in
the center people don't realize that you
don't always need to castle in every
game plenty of games have been won by
keeping the king in the center the
center is not an inherently dangerous
place to be
and g4 now we don't want to delay with
this move
this basically forces hg i mean if the
knight moves then we take the pawn on h3
and that's even worse
and hopefully you guys can see that
not only
does this remove
one of the pawns on the king side but
also as i said this brings the bishop to
g4 and this opens up the g file and also
the h file so we're doing 10 different
things with this one little pawn advance
and this is going to be incredibly
dangerous for white to play yeah i think
he senses that
um
that's that something has gone wrong
yeah well if white goes h4 then we win
the knight i mean the knight is hanging
knight h2 so he ends up going knight h2
all right thanks for the pawn
and not only do we win a pawn but we
still open up the king position
right if it was just winning a pawn i
wouldn't be quite as excited about this
ghgh
yeah but this is the worst version that
white could possibly get so what to do
now multiple uh attacking options i
think
that are available to us here
um
multiple attacking options the there's
the simple move rook g8 getting the rook
on a better square
uh we can play queen d7 and prepare to
castle long in case we need to
but i want an even more straightforward
approach yeah i think h5 h4
is incredibly hard to meet
i i like h5
because it threatens h4 it wins the
bishop
i don't see a satisfactory defense to
the move h4
if white puts his bishop on h4 that
opens up the g file then rook g8 comes
with even greater effect
if white moves the knight to f3 then we
can drop our bishop back to g4 and we
have that aforementioned devastating pin
um
i don't see a defense for white i think
it's basically over bishop h4 played
yeah opens up the g file now we put the
rook here
this basically forces the bishop back to
g3 if king h1 then bishop g2 g2 check
ends the game
yeah that's that's as fast as these
attacks sometimes go
and i want a game like this you know
against a gm once it was a rapid game
very similar type of attack
they can be so powerful that even strong
players have a very hard time defending
against these italian attacks
okay so obviously h4 wins the bishop
because it's pinned
and that's it
it's game
okay rookie three
now one little piece of advice is that
you don't necessarily need to rush with
taking the bishop
um since y does not escape the pin i
mean if i were to play king h1 then you
should take the bishop here i think we
can actually delay h takes you three by
one move and make an improving move
no knight h5 blunders the knight
the queen is defending that square but
what improving move have i mentioned in
the in the past in the recent past
which we could have played a little bit
earlier yeah i like queen d7 just
now that we're gonna win material it's a
good idea to at least have the option uh
to castle queenside and of course we
don't care about the f7 pawn this pawn
cannot be
less relevant to the position it will
allow white to take it and then move the
rook to g7
and the next move we can take the bishop
there was nothing wrong with taking it
on the previous movie there but i feel
like this is a little bit more clinical
okay and still we can
still we don't have to rush taking the
bishop
and in the spirit of what we're doing i
would actually once again
i think
we might find it a good idea to castle
and the secondary point is that we
connect our
okay knight f1
okay i'm
i've gotten impatient that's it
we're taking
let's take
it's about time
no need to play any more games
and i think if he takes on g3 with a
knight i have an instructive point to
make which is that
when you've won material right you don't
necessarily need to continue okay let me
phrase this another way when you're
attacking on one side of the board that
doesn't mean that you cannot play moves
on other sides of the board and the
whole chessboard is connected so
something that happens let's say in the
center
might very well impact your kingside
attack even if you might not see how
immediately and i'm thinking of a move
here that
if you kind of look at the whole board
you should be able to find it very
quickly yeah and that's the move d5 i
mean on a simple level we're up a piece
so opening up the center favors us also
his king is terribly weak what you'll
see is that in the event of a trade
we're going to be threatening a mate on
g2
i think you made in five and that's how
you know the center is connected to the
king side also we're just activating our
position
this bishop can come out to c5
additionally
skewering the rook to the king
yeah d5 is an active powerful move
that accelerates
our victory
okay
okay so takes takes
takes takes
and yeah this knight comes to f4 the
bishop comes to c5
this other knight can come out to d4
it's
totally devastating
totally devastating
okay takes takes yeah i think white
might go queen f3 and that will prolong
the game
this is definitely resignable but
probably at this level i would even
advocate for white to continue playing
this to be honest
it's normal but it's also normal not to
resign okay so queen f3 in the interest
of winning this faster
um let's keep the queens on the board
uh so what's the best way of keeping the
queens on the board where should we put
our queen
so try to find a square where the queen
defends as many pieces and pawns as
possible
um and that square is e6 yeah queen e6
is nice now you're not worried about
this
because the pawn on e5 is perfectly safe
this is another misconception not all
x-rays are inherently dangerous either a
very a lot a lot of them are
and you should keep tabs on this and if
white plays d4 you don't want to take
with the pawn for example but there's no
way that white is going to pressure the
e5 pawn
queen is not in any danger here yeah of
course we could have also played f5 and
probably won a second piece
king h1
it's a pin i apologies
okay let's get this knight to the center
yeah this is over
queen d1 queen c6 whatever f5 f4
anything wins
and if you go screen e4 we can take on
c2
yeah let's give him this check trying to
get a mate on g2 and if he covers on e4
we go f5 pinning tonight
if he goes pawn f3 then he loses the
knight on g3
and if he goes knight f3 we can drop the
bishop back to g4
boom yeah this is all extremely
straightforward i mean at this level now
that we've if we've hit 1300 i'm not
quite
commenting in as much detail on very
simple moves this is what i do in every
speeder on the higher rated i am the
less um i
pay attention to the really basic stuff
and the more i start paying attention to
higher level concepts and
uh you know stuff that starts to
bear more importance at an intermediate
level
94 f5 okay so what's the fastest win
here who can tell me
simple and immediate
anytime you have this arrangement bishop
and rook like this yeah bishop g2 bishop
takes f3 and we win the queen and
it's also basically made
we can primo bishop f3 if we want our
first premium of the speedrun okay your
signs
yeah very simple game nothing uh
nothing spectacular here i have a nice
game on this theme just to show you
really quickly
that
this italian attack with h uh h6 g5 g4
can get incredibly dangerous at every
level
and it's becoming increasingly popular
to play like this
so i won't analyze this game too deeply
but just watch how similar it is in a
certain sense
so this is a pro chessley game from 2018
this is a nice game um
so it's a similar opening a4 d6 c3
bishop a7 yeah and here he goes h3
which i think is actually a serious
inaccuracy if light doesn't follow it up
in the proper way and the moment he
played h3 i decided against castling
and so i decided to play
h6 g5 and g4
here he took bishop g4 and this is very
scary because now
this is a nasty pin
and now i maneuver my knight to h5
the queen comes to f6 the knight comes
to f4 you can just see how the storm
storm clouds are gathering around
white's king
my king stays in the center of the whole
game i can't even castle long here
either but i don't care takes takes
rookie 3 rook g8
now i decided to get my other rook into
the game
should d5 i mean there was a stretch
where
things got kind of tactically
complicated but the bottom line is that
i started winning all of his pieces
take this bishop c8
rook takes g3 check in the end
and this is
totally devastating
and i basically won all of his pieces
mate
the funny thing is the king got
checkmated on c1 or has it started the
attack on g1
um
you can find this game online or in the
database and take a look at it if you
want to but
yeah he decided to let me check my name
that's totally acceptable
um so if you're an e45 player which i
highly recommend in the speedrun
to be an e45 player
i gotta run uh but i hope you enjoyed
the game hope you guys have a good one
see you guys later bye
[Music]
you